life is good right now movies doing
great now I love it and comedy yes you
guys killing it your personal life your
personal life seems like it's going
great you got going out with this this
fellow who's running for president Cory
Booker hasn't the relationship going
it's been a while now really really well
yeah you know I've been working this
whole time so I haven't been able to see
him as much on the trail as I'd like and
that's where he is so I'm gonna be going
to Iowa with him soon tomatoes which I'm
really excited about wrap my head around
what it's like to be in a relationship
with someone who's running for president
I mean how is there oxygen left for a
relationship if you don't I'm saying it
must be difficult I don't know he sends
me a song every day that we don't wake
up together which immediately starts the
conversation
wait a minute let's back that up a
second he hasn't written a song has he
no I was gonna say for a second I
thought he writes you a song a new song
every day and I'm like that guy should
be President if he can do that you know
is it him singing into the phone he
doesn't know he's things to me all the
time actually but it's more just
different songs that he thinks of oh I
see you know just songs that meant a lot
to him when there was a big question
mark about whether or not he was gonna
find right I was gonna say if the
relationship goes south you've got all
those songs and great and singing